is age a legitimate issue it is a
legitimate issue sure it is and i think
people are going to judge it if i were
to run i think they're going to judge me
on my vitality can i still run up the
steps of air force two am i still in
good shape am i do i have all my
faculties am i
am i energetic i think it's totally
legitimate people ask those questions
you know i mean look what the world has
seen lately
how you doing people ah it was a bit of
a low blow but we just felt like going
with it it's july 7 2022 i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report we are live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
if you have not subscribed particularly
to the rumble channel or on blaze tv go
ahead and do that that is the future of
the online video situation for the free
people it ain't youtube it ain't twitter
or facebook or meta or any of that other
stuff so please
do join us you know i realize before we
jump into the q a that i should tell you
a little quick update on the twitter
thing do we have any questions about the
twitter thing the twitter suspension i
don't think so right so i should give a
little update right now so real quick in
30 seconds as you guys know and those of
you that are playing along especially on
locals no
i was suspended on twitter
for
screenshotting the fact that jordan
peterson was suspended on twitter
this then went viral then
that the fact that i was suspended and
ellen page's name because it was about
ellen page who is an actor tris now
known as elliott page something like
that uh ellen page started trending on
twitter then twitter
removed that trend because that is her
old name or his old name when he was she
etc etc it's all such nonsense anyway uh
yesterday i pro i posed the question as
to whether i should get back
on twitter or not uh to get back on i
would have to delete the tweet which in
some ways is sort of admitting guilt
that you somehow did something wrong
which obviously i did not do jordan
peterson in his really spectacular video
that we showed you a couple
half a minute or so of yesterday uh he
said that he was not going to delete the
tweet that basically who's going to
blink first who's going to cancel who
twitter
my feeling on this was that i was
willing to delete the tweet
because they tell you when you get
suspended this is a little insider
baseball stuff but i think you'll find
it interesting they tell you that if you
delete the tweet you'll be able to view
twitter
and you'll be able to send and respond
to direct messages those are your own
private messages that you can send back
and forth to people my feeling was if i
delete the tweet then at least i can
jump on twitter and alert people who are
on twitter like big influencer type
people that i have been suspended thus i
can get some you know public backing on
this thing and maybe they'll reverse the
suspension or at least i'll be able to
expose their hypocrisy whatever else and
then after that whether i want to use
twitter or not going forward will be my
decision so i did delete the tweet which
kind of sucked like it did not feel good
pressing that button like you're
admitting guilt to a faceless
organization that is run by woke leftist
lunatics it's not a it's not a fun thing
trust me
you could feel like a little soul just
sort of dissipating as you as you click
the button
but in any event i did do that and then
i really thought about it
uh yesterday all day long and i was
going back and forth with people on
locals people making solid arguments you
you just cut and run you let it be it's
trash twitter we all know it's trash
it's manipulated the shadow bands it's
ruining so much of everything you just
let it be and you go and you focus on
new things and then the other argument
of course is that no you have to fight
on their ground because there are still
people who you can bring to the sane
world uh that's still whether you like
it or not it is where the zeitgeist of
the the country and the world is so you
have to go back and fight so my feeling
was the latter uh so i am back and
fighting there uh but my relationship
with twitter obviously you know we're
all on borrowed time anyone any of you
that are watching this if you're on any
of the big tech platforms that you're on
you're on borrowed time uh and that's
why i'm so proud of what we're doing
with with locals and rumble and by the
way as i mentioned at the end of the
show yesterday so i did jump on truth
social as well and i have to say the
interaction there has been absolutely
incredible absolutely incredible like
tons of real people you can tell that
it's not bots it's not being manipulated
and all that good stuff so they're all
there are alternatives out there and i
just wanted to give you a quick update
on
that and uh we've got a community q a
for you today but we are going to do a
couple uh stories up top basically about
what the democrats are running on right
now what are these people actually
running on are they as crazy as we often
say that they are and and why are they
attacking the republicans who aren't
really in power right now and are the
republicans as mean as the democrats who
are in power are saying they are and
then what is it that the republicans
actually are running on that's what
we're doing today a quick reminder that
i will be at the miami improv on july
14th with ron desantis press secretary
christina pusha and i'm told there will
be a couple other surprise guests i
believe lisa booth from fox news will be
joining me uh my buddy dave boy who's
been on the show many times you can get
tickets at daverubin.com events and we
just opened up 40 more vip
tickets which i think we thought was
going to happen yesterday but it just
happened this morning so you can get
tickets daverubin.com events all right
let's talk about real estate agents i
trust and then we will get to the show
you know buying or selling a home is
already one of the most stressful things
you can do and it can be ten times worse
if you're not working with the right
agent generally speaking our homes are
our biggest investment definitely is for
me and that's a ton of responsibility so
you need an agent who takes that
seriously that's why i recommend real
estate agents i trust founded by my
buddy glenn beck they work with only the
best agents in every market they do
their homework talking to every agent
before
inviting them to join their network and
here's a big one they only work with
full-time pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied the
agents they work with have long track
records and are the best sellers in
their field they're a part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
including the free state of florida just
go to real estate agents itrust.com and
provide them with some basic info
they'll contact you to make an
introduction to an agent in your town
then you move and live happily ever
after okay so let's uh talk about what's
going on broadly with the left i'm
mostly going to be talking about this
from an american perspective as i am
here in the united states of america
although florida does feel like its own
country uh but that we all know that
there's this sort of this globalist
movement that we're all fighting right
now meaning that these western nations
that are supposed to be
independent liberal democracies are all
sort of coordinating with each other
when it comes to how they can
clamp down on speech for their own
citizen speech how they can force people
to be injected with things how the
monetary system seems to be working
there's this weird connection with all
of these countries i would say the worst
leader in the west right now
uh is a little north of me uh justin
trudeau he is a uh he's sort of like a
barbie doll with fancy socks who you
think is a nice guy and says all of the
nice things but under that very thin
veneer of most progressives lies a truly
authoritarian controlling whack job and
that is justin trudeau here's a little
freudian slip he had yesterday that we
thought was quite spectacular
leadership
and service opportunities for them
or whether it's our most
recent initiative on
banning
or sorry on freezing
the market for firearms
which will
start moving us in the right direction
over the medium and long term
these are things that
you all had voices in and i'm really
excited about not just hearing about the
impacts of these things but talking
about
how we continue to move forward you
gotta love it when these people say the
quiet part out loud he
accidentally
said that they are banning firearms what
he meant to say was they are freezing
firearms and of course we can have some
i suppose nuance conversation as to what
that really means a ban versus freezing
but i think you especially i know we
have a lot of viewers in canada uh you
guys know what's happening in your
country right now there has been a march
with this guy who has locked people in
his country
right at this very moment you cannot
leave canada if you are unvaxxed you
cannot leave by plane okay you cannot
leave by plane if you are unvaxed in
canada jordan peterson's father
could not attend his daughter michaela's
wedding which was in florida a couple
weeks back his dad has chosen not to be
uh vaccinated uh this is the same guy
who was freezing bank accounts of people
who were protesting his draconian
and all of the mandates and all of the
other stuff
he has made it clear we played a video
of him what two or three weeks ago
talking about how you don't have a right
to self-defense meaning someone can
break into your house and you cannot
shoot them sure they might be shooting
you or maybe stabbing you with the
machete something like that killing your
children but you don't have that right
to self-defense in canada and
technically actually he's right it is
not in any written document that the
canadians are governed by
we have something called the
constitution here in the united states
and we have something called the second
amendment in something called the bill
of rights that defends our ability to
defend ourselves it did not give us the
ability it defends our ability to do
that so justin trudeau when he says that
there he's really telling you now i get
it it might have just been a flub right
everyone flubs when they speak every now
and again but sometimes you get a
freudian slip that's just too perfect
right now he's saying there's going to
be this freeze on firearms but really
where do you think this thing is going
has anyone on the left ever
let's say in these last five six years
that that this woke thing has blown up
across the west have they ever stopped
has there ever been a point where enough
is enough
we got what we wanted let's all rest for
a moment right we created the earth
let's rest on the seventh day no they
don't do that they keep going and keep
going and keep going so he may want to
freeze on firearms right now i believe
that that is where they're at right now
but what he really wants is a man now he
will always travel
with security with firearms and his
friends will always have firearms and
the ability to defend themselves
it's ironic i mean it's like if someone
attacked justin trudeau yeah he doesn't
have to defend himself because a guy
with a gun will defend justin trudeau
but that is what these guys are all
about when you talk about elites
people who want a certain set of rules
for them and a complete other set of
rules for you that is what they want
justin trudeau is not a good dude now
that sort of sets up where i want to go
with the rest of this because that
concept this move on guns we know this
is happening in the united states of
america right now but as i said
thankfully we have the second amendment
although we have plenty of politicians
mostly democrats but a couple
republicans as well
who are all about uh seeing what they
can do to erode
our second amendment rights but what
else is going on uh in the world what
else is happening uh on the left side of
the political aisle that's a little
bizarre well uh we've got these high gas
prices have you heard about this and uh
there is this guy
that we're allowed to blame for all of
our problems this vladimir putin guy if
you've got a problem whatever your
problem is you got a bum knee uh you got
a window that's uh stuck uh whatever
your problem is in life you got a
headache whatever it might be bad hair
day whatever you blame putin okay you
never take responsibility that's what
they do uh here's pete buddha judge gay
pete he was on fox business and uh he's
very confused about what's going on here
half of that increase started prior to
the first russian soldiers arriving near
ukraine you can't blame it all on
ukraine right what about the other half
well what about the other half that's
pretty important
your administration has blamed this on
the the you know the war and that was
certainly a big factor but gas prices
had gone up
50 already before the war so to me
that's half of the blame not all the
blame
okay so just to be clear once again uh
gay pete who is our transportation
secretary has no expertise in
transportation he was hired because he
was gay that's what they do they love
diversity equity and inclusion you don't
have to be qualified for a job uh much
like our black lesbian press secretary
you don't have to be good at what you do
you just have to have an immutable trait
to get the job our deputy health
secretary rachel levine is trans uh this
is what these people do so you wonder oh
my god why is it that everything seems
like it's collapsing and it's like oh
well are any of the people in charge
qualified for their position or do they
have the mental acumen joe biden to
actually do the job that they're in and
the answer of course is no across the
board uh what pete is not uh fully
understanding there or fully admitting
is that as i have told you guys many
times gas was up a dollar fourteen
before one troop was in ukraine before
russia did anything with ukraine gas was
already up and
irregardless as the kids say
irregardless of
whether putin went into russia or not it
is the responsibility of any
administration to manage problems you
cannot go oh my god that guy over there
did some bad stuff there's nothing we
can do and if you want to defend the
liberal world order which is what they
keep telling us then yes you're gonna
have to suck it up and pay higher gas
prices and pay higher food prices and
all sorts of stuff no that is not what a
leader does what a leader does is say oh
there's some bad stuff happening over
there what is it that we can do here
what is within my power
to do here to stop those prices from
going up but biden keeps telling us
we're at war we're at war time nobody
knows really what this war is about by
the way congress of course has not
authorized this war but he keeps telling
us these are not normal times
and we've got to just keep giving
ukraine money i do not think we should
be giving ukraine a dime as you know
rand paul basically when they were given
40
billion dollars to ukraine
40 billion dollars and i'm sure that'll
be spent well uh he asked for receipts
just literally basically receipts uh
guys do you have uh microsoft excel can
we do a basic spreadsheet on this so
we're giving you 40 billion how much is
going to french fries can we get some
info here and uh the whole congress they
freaked out the senate and everybody
because they because this is just a
giant swamp grift that's what it is so
of course pete has nothing really to say
there because not only was gas going up
before
russia but it's their own policies and
the endless printing of money you guys
get it okay fine but not only are they
getting more authoritarian justin
trudeau and more dishonest gay pete
they're also getting more sadistic i
mean this one really
is twisted this is a fake native
american elizabeth warren who is a
senator up in massachusetts she is a
communist and a socialist who
is all about public school although of
course she sent her kids to private
school she's also worth
67 million dollars i should write a
children's book about the socialists
worth 60 the 67 million dollar socialist
it sounds like something doesn't it uh
here she is and she's freaking out
because uh there are places where you
can go these pregnancy centers that will
sometimes convince you not to have an
abortion and she just loves dead babies
senator warren also taking aim at
pregnancy crisis centers here in
massachusetts
these so-called
crisis pregnancy centers
outnumber
genuine abortion clinics by
three to one she says women walk into
the centers believing they'll get
abortions instead they try to talk women
out of it she calls it a bait and switch
they are giving it over to people who
wish them harm and that has to stop we
need to put a stop to that in
massachusetts right now
they are giving it over to people who
wish them harm that is one of the most
sadistic twisted statements i have ever
heard
these people that work at these
pregnancy research
resource centers they're non-profit
organizations and basically what they do
is what was laid out right there women
come in and they say hey i'm struggling
financially but i'm pregnant or i have
whatever it might be my boyfriend
abandoned me my parents aren't happy
about this i'm 16 years old whatever it
might be they offer free pregnancy
services they try to connect you with
community members they offer financial
services and they make sure that you're
going to get the medicines that you need
etcetera etcetera yes they try to
encourage people to go to term with the
pregnancy and then maybe adopt send the
baby to adoption or whatever it might be
rather than abort the baby
that is good
that is good it doesn't matter what your
position on abortion is it really
doesn't matter whether you are
completely pro-life or completely
pro-choice the idea that if there's a
way
that a woman wouldn't have to have an
abortion and a non-profit can do that
and volunteers can help that woman make
that decision that is good but she
really it's a bait and switch they go in
there thinking that they're gonna have
an abortion and next thing you know they
walk out and they haven't had abortion
and then they have to have that freaking
baby
this is modern child sacrifice with
these people they are they are
completely out of control and what's so
twisted about their control is they
really believe it i mean uh that woman
elizabeth warren really believes that
she's the good guy in this situation
that if that woman who goes there who's
four months pregnant 18 weeks pregnant
whatever it might be walks in there and
she goes in thinking she's going to have
an abortion and she's feeling some
kicking and we know that there's a
heartbeat and all of those other things
um
and then she walks out and that baby's
not sucked out of her and dead
she thinks that that's bad
what else can you call that beyond child
sacrifice these people are absolutely
out of control
but speaking of out of control the man
in charge of these democrats is the
elderly gentleman known as joseph r
biden he was in the government for 47
years before becoming president of the
united states and apparently never got
anything done in those 47 years which is
why he had to run as president
but he's trying to freak people out
because he knows he's not doing a good
job so instead of addressing any of the
problems he's really trying to scare you
about republicans
ask yourself this question what is a
republican platform going to this
campaign
no no i'm in deadly earnest i'm not
trying to be just just a fact
so he's being deadly earnest what is the
republican
platform well i have a couple ideas here
that could be related to the republican
platform there are things that are
happening right here in florida which is
run by a republican
named ron desantis if you haven't heard
of him great guy how about lowering gas
prices would that be something that
republicans basically are into more than
democrats of course the answer is yes
democrats want gas prices to be high so
that you'll be forced to go into debt to
buy an electric car even though it's
unclear to them where electric cars are
actually powered from if they found that
out they might not be so into it but
they're telling us we have to in essence
go through this rough transition off
fossil fuels so we can get to aoc's
green new deal so i would say lowering
gas prices that's one thing republicans
want uh two how about lowering inflation
you guys print a whole [ __ ] ton of money
all the time then you blame putin when
costs go up and the rest of it uh and
the you know the dow jones and
everything else is crashing all that
stuff the recession that we're in
although it hasn't been fully declared
yet um i would say printing less money
that would be a republican position at
this point avoiding nuclear war that
seems like a good one any of you into
nuclear war anyone no i got big nose
there nobody wants a nuclear war but you
know we are in this war not war
with russia right now democrats have
been pushing for a no-fly zone democrats
are pushing to give them all sorts of
money democrats are pushing to give them
all sorts of weapons at some point when
the guy who the whole world has turned
against uh realizes that he has troops
on every side of him and we're just
funding this war even though we're not
in a war you know something like that he
might go oh you know i've got a nuke and
i'm kind of pissed so i would say not
getting into nuclear war would be a good
one uh how about having a border
and wanting to reduce fentanyl from
infecting all of our streets in our
cities a border would be good you guys
know that basically since biden has
taken over the southern border is
basically it's not a border you want to
come to america walk right in although
you can't come in from canada by plane
if uh if justin trudeau has anything to
do with about do about it um how about
this is the fifth one i'm just going
through a whole bunch here how about
teaching kids not to hate each other by
race that is very much a democrat policy
at this point you guys have gone full
woke you love critical race theory which
is racism it's just a repackaged racism
so how about not that that would be good
uh i got another one for you how about
not sexualizing children
i thought that one was pretty obvious
but you guys are all into it right
you want
public school teachers and other people
other than the kid's parents to be able
to have private conversations with kids
about sex and gender identity and
sexuality and a whole bunch of stuff and
then hide it from parents you're a bunch
of weirdo freaks how about uh
republicans just aren't into that that
would be pretty good um how about uh
this is good as long as we're talking
about the school one how about
permitting kids to go to school that's
pretty good we may not like what's going
on in school but generally sending kids
to school and not having to wear
pointless masks on their faces
for a disease that's basically gone that
basically was proven that the masks
don't work in the first place and the
vaccines were unnecessary for kids et
cetera et cetera how about that that's
more of a republican principle than a
democrat principal and then finally i
would say how about letting people say
and believe what they want online right
because you guys love big tech
censorship right this administration we
know for a fact that this administration
they have admitted it several times they
actually go ahead and flag posts for
facebook so facebook can take things
down it's as close as you can get to a
direct violation of the first amendment
without maybe completely technically
tripping over that line so i would say
those are all republican principles at
this point it doesn't mean the
republicans are great it doesn't mean
they always live up to those principles
but it's a hell of a lot better than
what the democrats are doing so do not
believe joe biden when he says that
and of course speaking of joe biden you
can't believe his number two cackling
kamala harris
while you work hard
to teach the principles of liberty and
freedom in your classroom these
so-called leaders are taking freedoms
away
[Applause]
freedom away from women freedom
away from a kindergarten to third grade
teacher in florida to love openly and
with pride
[Applause]
it's so stupid that was a rare moment
where all three of you were groaning at
the same time that's what happens when
we put kamala videos on um look the idea
that democrats care about freedom or
liberty is so patently absurd that i
don't think you need me to go on for
that one um but it's it's just
incredible i mean they are just the
reverse of everything that they purport
to be but of course what she's saying
there about the don't say gay bill in
florida which has nothing to do with gay
it has nothing to do with a teacher
loving whoever the flying flip that
teacher wants to love but it has nothing
that teacher can't bring that into the
school when i was going to school
imagine your third grade teacher in
school trying to think of my old my
third grade teacher i actually loved her
name was mrs kochenhauer she was about
75 years old she read us the
secret garden i remember we would have a
reading hour we'd read the secret garden
and she would play out all the
characters in different accents great
woman
why would i care about her sex life this
is kathy now her sex life why would i
care about that why would anyone care
about their teacher's sex life why would
you want a state employee talking about
sex and gender with kids but they twist
everything they twist absolutely
everything so what's actually going on
here in florida because that's really
where they're focusing on because
florida's going so well what's actually
going on well we're
not banning books but we are banning bad
ideas we're banning you wouldn't teach
nazism in school would you well the
democrats might but here's what ron
desantis is up to
we're here today
because we believe
in education
not indoctrination
we are not going to use your tax dollars
to teach our kids to hate this country
or to hate each other
you know that's what's going on here
it's nothing scary it's nothing about
banning ideas it's about actually
opening up good ideas and teaching
things to kids that they're supposed to
learn in school hey how about math how
about a little honest history as opposed
to this brainwashing critical race
theory and wokism and gender nonsense
and everything else and one more from
ron desantis because he is using the
levers of government effectively i don't
love the levers of government but i do
love good governance and that's exactly
what he's doing here in florida the bill
that we're going to sign today is called
the no patient left alone act and it
increases patient protections and
ensures florida families have a
fundamental right to visit their loved
ones receiving care in florida hospitals
hospices and long-term care facilities
the bill bans
facilities from requiring visitors to
show
proof of covet vaccination also policies
cannot prohibit physical contact such as
hugging between their loved ones they
would actually police this where you go
in and you said okay you may be able to
go but you can't give uh your wife a hug
or you can't give your
your kid a hug i mean give me a break
and so we need to be able to protect
that uh this ensures families can be
there and patients can have their
support system around them when it
matters most
what a bad dude what a scary dude making
sure that people can see their loved
ones as they're potentially on their
deathbed or when they're sick at
hospital or make sure you can hug
your husband or wife or son or grandma
or whatever it might be but that is what
they're freaking out about
and man if it ain't clear if it ain't
clear to you guys right now i know it's
clear to you guys but for your friends
and for your uh if you visit the local
mental institution every now and again
and you need to talk to people and
they're running around because donald
trump and they've got trump derangement
syndrome and the republicans are coming
to get me
well if you got any of those in your
life uh maybe show them some of these
videos and and let them see what reality
is okay guys we did a whole it was a
long intro to a q a here we go we'll try
to plow through him real quick
tanya says might you consider a
political career in the future
i mean
well i will tell you this i did
some of you know this i did consider
running for governor of california i had
a lot of people in california like major
influential people reaching out to me
about that i was probably short of larry
elder i was probably the most outspoken
californian really going hard and going
after not only for the recall but
against gavin newsom i ended up
obviously supporting larry and and
campaigning with him and everything else
um but you know i don't know
that i could do all the bad things that
you sort of have to do to be a
politician now there are some
politicians who have figured out a way
around it and hopefully that'll continue
to turn i don't sense that ron desantis
is doing those things and he's been able
to win he's been able to effectively
beat the attacks ignore the attacks go
on the offense when needs need be he
hasn't had to get into all of those
games but it is a freaking dirty
disgusting game i have lived a life you
know and i don't know that i would drag
my you know i'm about to have a family a
full family with children and i don't
know that i want to drag them into that
and that's what sucks about politics
because then you're going to only get
the worse that politics gets the worst
people that you will get in politics
because good people good functioning
people who can create things and know
how to build things and do things will
just be like why would i do that uh why
don't i go off into the private sector
where it is not as disgusting and vile
and where i may not be personally
destroyed and where i can make some
money and all of those things so i don't
know i could see myself maybe if
anything like maybe when i'm like close
to retirement late 60s 70s something
like being the mayor of a small town
like in the middle of nowhere something
like that i think could kind of be
interesting but for now i think i can
affect politics
better from from this very desk right
here ryan says what's the weirdest
question
someone here has ever asked you
what's the weirdest question someone
here oh from locals well i'll tell you
the weirdest question that i was ever
asked in person this was um this was a i
was still living in l.a this was before
lockdown when people were allowed to go
up to people and talk to them a woman
came up to me and she said that she was
a lesbian and she wanted to have kids
and she asked for my sperm
she asked for my sperm beckelson's i'm
not kidding i was in the produce aisle
and she wanted my sperm which i felt
like in the produce i was totally
inappropriate and these things aren't
bad they're out there you know um so
anyway we went over to the the bread
island we took care of business no no um
no i just did not give her my sperm but
i thought that was an odd thing to ask
where can i have your sperm i don't know
you
but she didn't know where to get sperm
so you know what are you going to do
loves says during the trump
administration the red state governors
used to trade best practices to help
each other states do you know if they
still do and if
if not could you encourage florida and
texas governors to do that uh well if
you want more info on just that you
should watch my interview with south
dakota governor christie gnome from last
week because she talks a lot about that
how the governors
especially once biden took over we're
really trying to coordinate together
because the red state governors that is
because you know trump one of the things
trump did remember they all kept saying
he was hitler and uh what did he kept
saying hey states figure it out for
yourselves because you know what hitler
always wanted to do he always wanted to
give power to other people right he
always didn't want to take power for
himself he kept shifting it to the other
to the regular people that was what
hitler was always doing um it was always
one of the ironies of the way they
treated trump it was like when he didn't
they would call him hitler and then it's
like but hitler's not doing enough we
want more hitler anyway christina talked
about that quite extensively about how
the red state governors coordinated um i
was actually at an event uh was about
two weeks ago now with governor desantis
and he held a governor's a red state
governor's conference that they had a
few influencers at we all got to chat
and most of it was private some of it
was
semi-public i would say
where he is coordinating with some of
the other governors and they're really
figuring it out and i think we just need
more of that we need more confederacies
of functioning states versus woke crazy
blue states and then we'll see what
happens uh vince says who's bringing you
back online in september and what is
your prediction for the craziest thing
that will happen while you're away uh i
don't know if i can give away who is
bringing me back but it's a big one you
will be happy about it it is a big one
that's all i can say for now uh we will
be doing it live here in miami locals is
building a studio right now and uh it
will be at the local studio so i'm
excited about that um i think it'll be
at the local studio maybe said too much
right there we shall see uh but um
what's the craziest thing that can
happen while i'm away i mean
it's like trump could announce he's
running for president a whole series of
other people uh joe biden could break
the hip um you know last year we had
this crazy withdrawal from afghanistan
that i didn't know about till i came
back like literally anything could
happen there's almost nothing that
would surprise me you know andrew cuomo
resigned last year and i
when corolla told me on september 1st i
said i don't know who is replacing him
but i guarantee it'll be someone worse
and now we got this kathy c word um the
year before that kamala harris was
announced as the vp i mean big things
happened john mccain passed away one
august when i was off the grid um but
it's like literally anything could
happen putin could nuke ukraine the the
you know they could bring back kovid
monkey pox zombie apocalypse alien
invasion who the hell knows uh but for
us personally this year you know we're
gonna have a baby and we've been doing a
lot of work here and we're just looking
forward to just decompressing and
relaxing and
i suppose enjoying our our last little
bit of time before the baby arrives and
then and then just welcoming a new part
of life and i look forward to sharing
that with you guys uh laughs says since
the fear of rising covid cases has been
reported lately should someone tell us
how many of these cases are of the
vaccinated is kovit back are they
bringing covet back i did notice a few
more masks
the other day
and you don't see many masks here in
florida
i don't think they'll ever give us
honest numbers i think you got to make
decisions for yourself but i can tell
you this i and i know i said this once
and people said this on twitter and i
got a ton of hate and uh you know people
say mean things to me on twitter i don't
ask them to be banned um
i don't know anyone
that did not get vast that wishes they
got back
including myself including the guys in
the studio it's like i i actually wear
the non-vaccine as a point of personal
pride at this point because we all know
the pressure that was brought to bear
for all of us not only the public
pressure and you might lose your job and
i know some people nurses and all sorts
of people everyone had to make horrible
the government forced us to make
horrible personal decisions unfathomably
difficult decisions and then that is
they should not be forgiven for that uh
but i'm very proud that i that for all
of the push that i got
family
work all of the pressures that i didn't
there were times i almost lost my nerve
dave and i had one final conversation
where i was like you know what maybe we
should just do it this headache and not
being able to go anywhere and all of
this stuff and and somehow we decided
not to do it and i'm very very proud of
that but to answer your question no if
covid comes back or when they bring kova
back they will never tell us the real
numbers on who's getting it and relative
to being vaccinated or not i mean
anthony fauci's got covered right now
he's 18 times vaccinated right uh
mccormick says within two minutes of
meeting a person what are some key
pieces of insight
uh or what what are some key pieces of
insight are you most often able to
garner about them
you know i'd say generally
i i'd like to think as an interviewer
i'm a pretty good judge of character so
i can usually pretty much get a vibe
from somebody if i kind of like them or
not or if i see something's there if i
get like a weird feeling i think you
just have to be present you know if
you're just as present as possible
you won't find that you know you're
going to be like boy i really welcomed
this person into my life and they turned
out to be someone else not to say you
can't have the wool pull over your eyes
it's happened to all of us it sometimes
happens to me in a public sense um but i
think if you just kind of if you're
straight up with people they'll
hopefully be straight up with you or or
you'll notice that they they can't or
won't be uh ryan says of all of the
political leaders you've met and
interviewed who did you think were the
top two most authentic well desantis by
far i mean
and i i know i live in florida i talk
about him a lot and all that stuff but
desantis now that i've spent some time
with him and you know we had this uh 20
minutes just in the green room with the
two of us and then he was chatting with
my staff and i told you the story about
when i introduced phoenix to him he's
like phoenix phoenix from the book oh
phoenix good to meet you like he read
the book like he he's a good guy he
wanted to talk about baseball uh you
know he played baseball in uh college
and i grew up in long island he used to
go to long island to play baseball like
he's just a good he's a good dude like
he really is and i've spent some time
with the first lady and she's really
these are just normal people that happen
to be politicians which is how it's
supposed to be so i would just say
desantis number one and i'd say
number two and this one may sound a
little hard for you guys to believe but
i'd say ted cruz uh ted cruz who i i you
know i before i met him
when he was running against trump i felt
he had like a little bit of like a used
car salesman vibe or something like that
and then i met him a couple times and
then i interviewed him in person and we
played nintendo together and he gets
simpsons references and signed for
weapons he's really funny uh he's smart
he's a good guy he loves basketball um i
regret not supporting him earlier in
that whole thing i mean trump was
destined to become president either way
um but you know sometimes there's some
people that that are a certain way on
camera and i think ted's actually gotten
a lot better i think bearded ted cruz is
a lot better than pre-bearded ted cruz
probably like dave rubin um
so yeah i'd say cruz he's he's a genuine
he's funny he's like like when i'm with
him i'm like yeah i could be friends
with this guy like in in real life um
blee says what are your top three
favorite movie comedies ones you can
watch over and over well this is very
easy as well naked gun is the funniest
movie of all time without question i
have seen it four
billion times and it is there is nothing
better than naked gun leslie nielsen at
his peak it's just absolute comedy
perfection if you have not seen it you
must watch it it's just wonderful i'm
pretty sure it's on netflix um
uh let's see number two i'd say best in
show you know those christopher guest
movies that's the one about the the dog
show it's basically a perfect comedy
sort of like very cerebral kind of weird
quirky stuff and then i'd say and this
is sort of like saying naked gun but
airplane which was the zucker brothers
who did
naked gun and of course leslie nielsen
was an airplane uh airplane was what
year what year was airplane about 77 if
i'm not mistaken i think it's about 77
naked gun was probably 89. so it's a
precursor to naked gun in a lot of ways
i think they perfected that brand of
slapstick comedy by the time naked gun
came out i remember seeing a naked gun
in the theater i was 12 years old i'm
pretty sure it was 1989. and laughing so
hard the audience was cracking up that a
fat man sitting in front of me i was
sitting in an aisle seat a fat man in
the aisle in front of me fell out out of
his chair into the aisle fat man in the
aisle it doesn't get any better than
that when you're at a comedy movie
airplane 1980 all right i was close ry
says what were two interviews you did
that you may uh may not have been the
most notorious or famous but were ones
that you felt were your personal best
when you utilized all of your potential
wow that is a good one well the easy
answer for that one although he's quite
notorious obviously uh notorious thought
of as a negative word but i don't think
it always is um
the thomas soul interview because the
reason i think it was using my best
skills was because soul has been
interviewed a gazillion times right he's
he's been through all of the interviews
all the different styles all of those
things and i was very aware that i have
a relatively young audience that we did
this a couple years ago and you know the
online thing was still on its way up and
the mainstream thing was on its way down
and i felt i had a duty
to myself and the audience to how can i
introduce this legend to these people
but also have it be interesting for him
because otherwise it's just like okay he
can just repeat his greatest hits right
but at that point i could just put play
clips of him for you guys and that would
be enough so i was really aware of how
do i sort of do something that's kind of
thomas soul 101 but also but also more
than that and also interesting to him
and i really think i did it well and i'm
very very proud of that interview i
would say one other one although she has
become quite famous and notorious
is my first interview with candace owens
which can we get the date on that what
was the date on that first interview
with candace owens we were doing
something called youtube week this is
probably five years ago
and i would just pluck youtubers that i
thought were interesting i did not even
know candace owens name when she sat
down in my garage believe it or not she
was known as red pill black and she had
like 50 000 subscribers something like
that she was just this unknown girl she
had put up this funny video about mom
and dad i'm a conservative i'm a black
conservative and i was like let's just
sit down and talk this was back in
september of 2017. so about five years
ago now
and
i think the reason it was one of my best
was because
she was unknown she was definitely a
little nervous she was trying to figure
out what all her ideas were but we had
to kind of do that dance together and i
kid you not
that interview finished she went to the
restroom and i said to david that girl
is going to light the world on fire i
knew it i knew it candace ended up
staying
at the house for like 10 hours we had
chicken parm that night and and
obviously we've become great friends
since um but i think it used my skills
properly because i was like man there's
something really here with her but i
don't even know who she is exactly or
what she's really about and then
obviously it turned into a whole other
thing kyle says what are you listening
to these days any new music worth
sharing well i don't listen to any new
music i don't know
michael what are you listening to
michael likes the new music every time i
play music in the car
i play 70s music 50 i love the 50s right
i love the 50s 60s 70s 80s obviously i
don't listen to that michael won't
listen to anything that is more than two
weeks old what are you listening to now
odessa odessa
okay that's banned
there okay odessa is what michael's
listening to if you like the stuff for
the young kids uh i am lis you know i do
a lot of ambient stuff around the house
i'm loving um
right now for because when we're when i
have my whole crew here and we're
working throughout the day uh i'm loving
the rippingtons you guys know the
rippingtons rippingtons and russ freeman
just really great fun ambient stuff to
listen to i listen to a lot of chill
that kind of thing but you know my old
my old go-to is always
uh you know frankie valley in the four
seasons i love sinatra i love
dean martin oh but you know really more
than anything else right now especially
when my day closes and i'm kind of just
my kitchen's under construction right
now i'm grilling outside and relaxing
i'm loving some yacht rock man i am
really into the yacht rock right now
loving it christopher cross
uh i'm loving the doobie brothers really
into the doobie brothers michael
mcdonald i'm i'm feeling a very i guess
that's early 80s vibe these days uh
maybe i'll post my i have a yacht rock
channel that i created on on spotify and
of course sinatra and all that stuff
um kelly says do you think there's a
snowball's chance in hell
that newsom could ever get the
democratic presidential nomination are
people not stupid
kelly
yes people are that stupid and if i had
to bet
if i was a betting man i would bet that
gavin newsom will be the nominee they
have such a thin bench over there it's
such a collection of lunatics and crazy
people and psychopaths and devil
worshippers
and child sacrifices and a whole bunch
more that newsom is just perfect he is
the perfect modern democrat by the way
newsome right now he's vacationing in
montana which is a red state that the
state of california has banned uh its
employees from doing business with
because of their anti-gay policies in
montana yeah they're coming for the gays
in montana i mean wasn't brokeback
mountain in montana where the hell is
brokeback mountain or is it georgia
maybe google it guys what are you
looking at me for where the hell was
brokeback mountain
but the point is uh i think it was in
georgia i think it was georgia maybe it
was montana no we'll find out in just a
sec but anyway he's vacationing in a
state that he doesn't want public
employees going to but that's just per
you know any you know there's the whole
french laundry thing
brokeback mountain was in alberta canada
it's about wyoming oh but it's about
wyoming thank you thank you yes okay the
actual brokeback mountain is in canada
but brokeback mountain the movie was in
wyoming interesting
filmed in canada but took place in
wyoming duly noted thank you very much
he's a bad dude uh he is soulless he
will say anything he is a liar and a
fraud and he's just a perfect democrat
so yeah it's probably going to be him uh
amy says what is your biggest fear about
parenting two boys so close in age
uh well david and i have talked about
this a lot i mean
i hope they like each other i hope that
they want to hang out together you know
because in essence by having
two boys that are just a few months
apart you know they'll most likely will
have to figure it out it'll depend on
development and everything else whether
they're going to be in the same grade
and everything so people will think of
them as twins regardless of whether they
end up in the same
grade uh people will see them and be
like oh these are twins we have we
already bought the stroller we got the
back to back you know side by side
stroller it's like people oh you have
twins so i hope that they'll enjoy being
with each other and they'll like the
same things hopefully hopefully they'll
like basketball more than soccer that's
one of my main hopes uh hopefully when
they're playing video games they're
going to want to run that way or that
way and not that way connor you know i
struggle when i have to run into the
screen i can do super mario that way i
can jump over turtles and things i can't
really go that way
i'm working on it um but i guess the
main yeah we just want them to to like
each other and hopefully be buddies
dragon says do you feel like biden has
been put out as a sacrificial lamb to
get these radical policies in place and
the left doesn't care about his approval
rating yes yes yes i've been saying it
for a while and it's starting to leak in
mainstream they are done with biden he
doesn't know it but he is dead man
walking he's obviously not running again
he most likely won't get to the end of
the term you can see the machine going
against him aoc and others talking about
how they're not fully in support of him
he has been a disaster at every level
but it worked
devil is due right
it worked they got him in he was the guy
that they could get in as they pretended
that they were still moderate they will
not be moderate going forward it will be
gavin newsom or one of the squad or
something like that it is going to be
such a clown car of awful people i mean
think about it from two years ago so you
had biden you had klobuchar and gay pete
and the crystal woman and uh who and
kamala you did have tulsi who was saying
but you had a basically a really unburny
you had a really untalented uninterested
uninteresting group of people up there
who always were talking about what they
could do for you as long as you gave
them enough of your life
your life force in essence and your
money especially um as opposed to how
you could be free how they could get out
of your way to be free how they could
defend your freedoms but that's it uh
it's gonna be much worse but they but
they did it with biden they they pulled
the wool over the eyes they used the
people that had trumped arrangement
syndrome and they got a bunch of neither
here nor their liberals to to vote for
biden it was obvious to me that he stood
for nothing he's he's meaningless he is
a nothing meaningless shell and they
will be done with him soon enough jacob
says hey dave i know that you and david
go off the grid annually in august what
made you choose the month of august i
tried to go off the grid for news only
over the independence day weekend and i
loved it i may want to try it for a
month but i'm not sure which month to
choose so when i originally did this i
think this is going to be my sixth year
going off the grid for august it was
kind of like it was a lark it was sort
of a joke like i don't know let me just
see could i put my phone in a safe and
not pay attention to anything and see
what happens is that possible
and then i realized how great it was and
how i felt clean and clear when i came
back and i as i always say to you guys i
think it's one of the reasons that
politics did not destroy me and i
haven't been wrecked by all of this
where so many people do and they can't
do it with any joy
and they're so consumed by it it's like
i take one twelfth of the month of one
twelfth of the year not to care about it
i spend a lot of time caring about it
and those other 12 11 out of 12 months
um and i think it's really it's we're
doing too much of this we're all staring
down we got neck problems we got
shoulder problems we're where our
attention span is frayed all of those
things that's happening um so i do it to
an extreme meaning no phone no
electronics
none of it no news no newspapers it can
often be very difficult it limits the
places that i can go because there's
always tv places but i would say
my challenge to you watching this
is see what you can limit i mean even if
you can only do it over the weekend as
shapiro said to me once when i started
doing i started doing it over the
weekends first and shapiro said you do
know that there's something called
shabbat we've been doing this for quite
some time starting on friday night since
saturday night and it's like if you can
just do it
friday night to saturday night if that's
your tradition if you can do it on
sundays if that's your tradition you can
do it on both days great if you can make
sure that you're not looking at your
phone after 8pm i'm not saying i do
these things all perfectly all the time
i certainly do not but i would say one
other one other real tip that i think
has helped me do not keep your phone in
your bedroom do not wake up to have a
random anime he she avatar tell you to
go [ __ ] yourself it's not a great way to
start the day it's not guys it's not
connor's like it isn't it isn't a great
way i gotta stop doing that it's just
not a great way to start the day so
limit some of this stuff in your own
life and maybe you know
i know people i'm fortunate enough and
i've built businesses enough that i can
do this and my guys can keep working and
our businesses don't crash and
everything else but you can figure out
some way in your life to take a little
more control of it
creighton says elections are approaching
what's your 2022 october surprise
predictions i mean it's it's coveted two
or monkey pox something that they'll
really have to push for mail-in ballots
it could be that the war in in ukraine
whatever the hell this freaking thing
i'm tired of calling it a war whatever
whatever's going on there they just ramp
it up so that people will be afraid to
vote differently because you know when
we're at war during uh elections people
want to vote for the people in charge
because it's too scary to change the
people in charge even if they got us
into the non-war in the first place so i
think it's going to be a bunch of weird
stuff
mizzy says dave excited to see you at
the improv on the 14th we are canadians
who escaped and managed to get vip
tickets to your show just happy to be in
the free state of florida you have given
us so much encouragement thank you thank
you we would defect if we could not a
question but i will take that comment oh
and that's the last one so uh well
welcome and i can't tell you a ton of
canadians here in florida right now and
they know why they're here they know who
they fled justin trudeau they know why
they fled him lockdowns can't defend
yourself etc etc and uh florida is open
for anyone that wants to live freely and
that is a beautiful thing and if you
would like to join me and my canadian
friends on july 14th daverubin.com
events at the miami improv if you want
to submit questions when we do these
live q and a's you go to
reubenreport.locals.com the community is
blowing up right now because the twitter
suspension and everything else and
tomorrow it is friday so we've got a
roundtable extravaganza actor and
director and my buddy nick circy uh will
be joining us i believe for the is it
the first time
man i don't know how that happened first
time for nick circe uh sarah gonzalez of
the blaze and ezreal event of uh rebel
who's up in canada we'll see how much
longer he can do journalism up there and
finally i leave you with this
the man
in charge of america have a good one
everybody
a solid meeting
with um
with uh
[Music]
the uh
hello biden obama democrat
javier baccaria javier
mr secretary all right jack thank you
very much
all right it's chris but anyway i just
did chris yeah and i want to thank the
the
former general i keep calling in general
my
my uh the guy who runs that outfit over
there
i want to make sure we thank
the secretary jill and i've always
enjoyed seeing pete and kirsten
which i have done personally with with
with the president of china it was
president
my boss
senator shelly caputo
you may remember
i got in trouble when we were running
against
the senator who was a mormon
the governor okay the instagram question
answer with one of the leading soccer
players in the world the latest episode
of here's the deal podcast and andrew
young brought in a guy from illinois he
ended up being a great secretary of
transportation i mean secretary of state
every day
between an hour and an hour and a half
brief
with
a former head of a former surgeon
general
anyway they are holding up
the nomination of the president put
forward from the supreme court i want to
be clear
i'm not going nuts